lenta y constantemente se gana la
carrera la tortuga laúd es el reptil
conocido más rápido con una velocidad
máxima de 21.92 millas por hora cuál de
las siguientes ecuaciones donde d es la
distancia en millas y t es el tiempo
dado en horas representa una velocidad
que es menor que la de la tortuga laúd
seleccione todas las que apliquen vemos
que la velocidad de la tortuga laúd es
de 21.92 millas por hora sabemos que la
velocidad es una relación entre la
distancia en millas y el tiempo en horas
en este caso si quisiéramos escribir una
ecuación para la distancia que la
tortuga laúd recorre en una hora tenemos
que relacionar la velocidad que es de
21.92 millas por hora y nuestra ecuación
sería de igual a 21.92 de cualquier
coeficiente menor en esta ecuación
representa una velocidad menor a la de
la tortuga laúd tenemos que ver cuál de
estas ecuaciones representa una relación
entre la distancia y el tiempo
que nos indique una velocidad menor
cualquier coeficiente menor a 21.92
representa una velocidad menor a la de
la tortuga la uva
vamos a hacer una más algunos discos de
vinilo llamémosle all these giran a la
velocidad de 78 revoluciones por minuto
la tabla a continuación muestra las
revoluciones por minuto para tres pistas
diferentes en otro tipo de disco de
vinilo llamado woodies cual tiene una
mayor tasa de revolución all this could
is la tasa de revoluciones por minuto de
los oldies es de 78 y vamos a pensar en
las revoluciones por minuto de las
pistas que tenemos aquí en tres minutos
este hace 135 revoluciones cuántas
revoluciones por minuto son bueno
dividimos revoluciones entre minutos y
tenemos 135 entre 3 120 entre 3 son 40 y
quedan 15 el resultado es 45
revoluciones por minuto en la pista 1 en
la pista 2 también son 45 revoluciones
por minuto 45 revoluciones por 4 minutos
si nos dan 180 revoluciones
y en esta pista si multiplicamos 45
revoluciones por 5 minutos
nos da 225 revoluciones por minuto
vemos que los oldies van a 78
revoluciones por minuto y los woodies a
45 así que no solo dicen más
revoluciones por minuto que los woodies
los oldies tienen una tasa mayor de
revoluciones por minuto